we've always wanted to get West prudent
and Christopher Hitchins together one
from the right one from the left had no
idea they would come together at this
particular moment we might find an
interesting result so we'll start with
you mr. Hitchens and look at the front
page of The Washington Times the nones
admits shredding evidence is the lead
story up here but the continuing story
of the week down here is royal family
brings grief into public eye after much
criticism you've been on the telly as
they say talking about this what's your
take at this point in the story if the
top headline had referred to Mother
Teresa's in the perfect front page from
my point of view as it is to my
least-favorite forces that's to say that
the lovers of Princess Diana and the
lovers of the House of Windsor are
having a fight so it couldn't be better
I wish that's how it had been reported
only today did the thing begin to ments
of a news story in other words something
that could actually be reported for the
whole of the rest this week we've been
absolutely just drowning drool where the
coverage has not been the coverage
objective coverage of an event but the
sort of forced recruitment of everybody
into the same emotional mode a great
great Titanic outpouring of Kitsch in
other words wherever one is told that
they're all part of a great we and this
great we feels worth bound together and
enormously moved and hurt by something
that actually is a non-event Howard
Kurtz who writes for your competitor
here in the capital the Western post has
a story on media notes extra read all
about it over coverage shocks press
well this press is probably easily
shocked look this has been one great
opera winfrey show this week worldwide
and i have to say as as an angle file
that I'm really quite disappointed in in
in Britain where the tradition of the
stiff upper-lip has descended into you
know their their know something like
this comes up and everybody in London
seems to want to get on the Opera one
free show to Street Saturday yeah
exactly
like let me say first of all that I was
had to and when I heard the news that
Diana was dead but she was a lovely
beautiful woman what's also very
interesting about this is that she was
what we had a demonstration of this week
is how sad everybody is when a beautiful
woman dies like this if she had been
Mother Teresa say who really has
accomplished something and has done
something for the world there would have
been much south touring this but because
he is so beautiful
you know people responded in a different
way I was enraged the first night
because in rage maybe too strong a word
but the first coverage was the paparazzi
chased them to their death now I make no
defense of the paparazzi there you know
there are people who are unfeeling and
unsentimental and all that but here was
a man who was even if he was stone-cold
sober he was driving in a suicidal
manner at a hundred miles an hour or
whatever in a tunnel
absolutely asking for an accident
where was Dodi he you know / supposed to
be so greatly in love with this woman
why didn't he just lean forward and say
hey for God's sake slow down I think any
man had urged that responsibility to any
woman that he has in his care
let me throw this in there's a column in
The New Republic the new issue coming
out today the feast of Diana by William
powers this is the New Republic and it's
just one little paragraph here he says
Katherine Graham who publishes The
Washington Post in Newsweek announced
that the paparazzi are not in fact
members of the press informed of mrs.
Graham's remark a paparazzo paparazzo on
another show pointed out that a perusal
of news weeks pages would surely turn up
fine examples of his prefer professions
handiwork yes I saw mrs. Graham say that
and I rather flinched because it was all
part of the appalling self flagellation
and masochism of the profession the
sweet the fact is there it there's a
sinister side to this mass hysteria and
mass sentimentality it's not just it's
not just what I was describing to us
particularly and drooling it can be mean
to because it has a search for blame
which is part of the search for meaning
in an essentially meaningless event
people want to be able to attribute
responsibility of Princess Donna have
trodden on a land mine which I think
would've been a very fine way for her to
go that we could say in a sense of life
and death it had some me as it happens
she was killed in a sordid traffic
accident with a very sordid set of
people the International white-trash jet
said into what she hoped to marry
because no one wants to say that because
obviously there was a as you say as that
of the driver I mean a driver going fast
enough to get the Mercedes rady into the
front seat of the car picture the damage
there you know but we can't say that it
was the fault of her the set she was
running with because that would that's
not this week's story it doesn't make
her magical it doesn't make her
beautiful it doesn't make her a romantic
yes where's prettiness I thought the
whole the whole thing's been a wild
goose chase are there are seven members
of my profession not be in jail if it
wasn't for this ridiculous Asteria I
mean the French police simply escape
alerting photographers but they're out
now well they sure got to hear it but
they've charges still quite severe
against you had this piece in your
Wednesday paper children hooked on TV
stimulus fine school
I bring this story up it's it's a one of
your own reporters reported this passive
action destroyed
press is pretty well taken on the
television medium can you blame an
outfit like ms in I could from 20,000 to
a million on Saturday night or whatever
for seeing that this is a great story
for their future god blame them would
you um would I have done it I like to
think I would not have but and I'm not
in television news get on TV news a long
time ago is because I've preferred the
more serious print to
it's perfectly understandable why they
do it given the way television as but it
is you know I guess it was Richard Nixon
who once said the television is 2 News
what a bumper sticker is 2 philosophy
it's all built on sensation it's all
[ __ ] and that's what I meant by the
Opera went for a vacation of of news
this we all we all we want all
television news once now is as a Wall
Street Journal says cheap sentiment and
us give people a just nothing but cinema
and and let the facts be damned whether
they show those ratings are holding up
by the way I mean probably maybe I move
in the wrong circles but I didn't I mean
no I don't walk around Washington a lot
I don't see people in tears or queuing
up at the Berisha or anybody's grounded
in tradition I did go yes I saw some
people obviously in need of some are
there but what if I saw this guy's a boy
about 25 slightly overweight putting
down his flowers his cards and so on
they stopped in Austin you know what did
she mean to you and he said she was my
role model my very strong role model now
the cameraman the interview instead of
saying what do you mean role what you
mean model talking about just not it it
sympathetically and understandingly as
if yes of course that's just how we all
feel what is this what it's not living
in a one-party state Banana Republic
when the dear leader dies you'll
compelled your counted in doomed now as
a matter of fact everywhere else I've
been in Washington this week people have
been completely dry eyed so sure that
everyone wants to be treated in this way
but as oppression in other words by the
mass media it's one thing to cover it
it's another to be part of the story and
assume that we're all extras in it in
about five minutes we'll go to the calls
and calls to suggest that there folks
don't think the way you all do at this
table so we'll look forward to hearing
or even to are raising the questions but
let me show you an editorial is
probably the strongest there been a
bunch this week you had one times this
is in the Wall Street Journal on
Wednesday and I wanted read just a
little bit of it to show you how strong
the animus is toward the television
business from the print side is it
possible that there is any more normal
person out there who by now is not
grossed out and sickened by televisions
coverage of Princess Diana's death it is
remarkable to see a professional mindset
studiously reports the sins of the
tabloids in the paparazzi even as it
shows its own sump pumps deep in lady
Diana and runs the open hoses onto the
nation's living room floors yes the
recess of the word and surely a major
news event by whatever standards
currently apply so it is no surprise
that the venerable CBS program 60
minutes would devote its entire hour to
the subject but you knew that you had
stumbled into a world unique to
television when the program ended with
Dan Rather reciting a eulogy that rose
rapidly into the ethers his voice
breaking eyes welling and promising more
direct under the next night perhaps the
events most unintended moment of
apotheosis in which all the moons and
age of celebrity came into perfect
alignment occurred on ABC's venerable
Sunday morning from which David Brinkley
had the good fortune to retire before
this moment arrived when Sam Donaldson
himself denounced that Barbara Walters
delivered her thoughts quote from
Southampton unquote in Southampton miss
Walters appeared to in a study it's wall
lined with books causing an observer of
our acquaintance in one American living
room to remark it's to be sure it's all
quite obviously fake though the grim
deaths in a tunnel and the sympathy they
evoke are all to normal human sympathy
for the misfortune of others is not a
complex human emotion as an awake or in
a personal phone it has a simple direct
expression of concern and support the
hard part is in knowing when to give
what one can and went back to pull back
let me just stop there and get your
response well that's you know I couldn't
I could have written that ID because
they certainly expresses my sentiments
look what we had from the very beginning
the
coverage was every everybody wanting to
get a piece of Diana like the young man
at the British Embassy said she was a
role model and we got John Travolta
saying I want the I want that family for
those kids I'll stop whatever I'm doing
and fly over on a moment's notice
I suppose you know he thinks maybe this
week they'd like the VIP disco dancing
Tom Cruise was talking about I've been
in that tunnel I've been chased by
paparazzi in that tunnel a lot of people
who maybe saw Diana drive down the
street in a limousine
trying to say you know great friends
with her because everybody wanted to get
somehow get in on this opera win free
free-for-all in festive absolute
solipsism exactly jacanas magazine cover
just came in the tragedy of diana yeah
and everyone calling her a very sinister
when this vicarious identification goes
so far you you were even doing it
yourself mr. Putin as using the
celebrities first next it'll be oj or
Olli you start using their nicknames you
know it's very creepy I find I don't
like I said although actually did meet
her twice and I know her brothers I
don't know her well enough to call by
first name Doukhobor Princess Tiana
cousin or Royalists I call a dinosaur
the Spencer girl which I think is
respectful enough but I tried it on it D
this week and I nearly got blown out of
my chair with people all of whom it was
as if you know they were they were her
brothers and her family honor had been
insulted so that's what there's only one
line I'd change it later Toria this is
the last time I'll ever say a sentence
like that and that's they're wrong and
saying it's a tragedy in every sense of
the word it's not a tragedy in the
original Greek sense of the word
it isn't is there's no there's no
affection or tragic irony of action
involved in this at all it's a nasty
traffic accident in the jet-set in your
present times queen of local hearts
here's some local coverage this is
missus dole there and you've got Diana
at the Reagan White House in 1985 right
here and down below that is Ralph Lauren
at the Hyde Center for breast cancer
research here in town well look I we're
culpable ID
it we tried to pull back coverage a
little bit in midweek and it's you know
we were succumbed to the same temptation
that the works did although I like to
think that we have where do we didn't
give ourselves totally to the Princess
Diana or the Miss Spencer story morning
we do have what I think is the most
important story because the day at the
top of the page and that is the nuns
administrating a defense of the Al Gore
fundraiser
notice the neither the Washington Post
northern New York Times could find room
above the fold for that story I happen
to think that's the most important story
that they don't yesterday too
yes when you go on the Justice
Department having to reconsider even in
spite of the fact that there's no head
of the Justice Department of the moment
it seems it was no one in charge that
the scandal itself I must have I think
Washington times to be very good at
attention on the Thompson hearings on
that is actually one last question on
the for the hearings we talked about
this earlier and at first because you're
over on the left side of the spectrum
the New York Times has an editorial more
about mister and this morning they say
despite mr. Gore's famous comment that
no controlling legal authority
restricted his action he appears to have
broken what does that mean that the New
York Times would say something like that
in one of their editorials I figured is
finally or at last it seems to dawn on
them in up until now the whole thing's
been written up in a very euphemistic
manner and most of the press actually
said all the most they could find to say
about the Thompson hearings when they
began was no smoking gun which is a
moronic thing to say when actually great
disclosures are being are being brought
to us about how the last election if
anyone remembers that that sort of event
was bought and paid for
what is your take I mean to take off
your conservative hat for a moment why
is the New York Times doing this what
what do you think's going on inside
their editorial room well I think think
they don't want to be caught with their
pants down on as a story begins to
unfold obviously something is going on
here and
as newspaper editors they know they can
recognize a story when it's coming down
the road down the pike Adam as mr.
Hitchens says finally and in the
editorial page of the New York Times has
always been a little ahead of the news
department in this whole Clinton scandal
Factory down 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
so I think that's probably what's
driving and there is a like you a
southerner that runs that page mr. rains
is that everything to do with a well as
somebody once said southerners Jews and
Irish make the best newspaperman to so
the are the the southerners for the love
of the language the Irish for the booze
and the Jews for the chance to do social
justice Philadelphia good morning you're
on the air
morning Brian I want to give some kudos
to your two guests because I am
absolutely sick and tired of this
incessant coverage of this this traffic
accident people don't realize that
25,000 people a year die in the United
States from drinking and driving and
this is just another accident that
happened and also I want to make one
comment about the criticism to the royal
family I'm not British or anything like
that but who of these people who are
criticizing the royal family doesn't
have a divorce in their family where
they disliked at least one of their
in-laws Thank You mr. Hitchens um in
case that was for me it was for anyone
would it would indeed apply but that
isn't the debate but I will only say
that that's not the basis of my
criticism of the royal family
let me grab another cockerel against the
reddit free principal is the means of
picking the head of state so I would be
against that even if they were all
happily married in a managed to stay in
touch Beverly Hills California Thank You
mr. Lam I'm very happy to get on with
mr. Hitchens because I think he's
phenomenal but there is so much truth in
the whole thing about how the coverage
was done about Diana dying
it is a shame but actually I think the
TV has done just the same as the
tabloids of done
they have created a monster that every
channel you turn to same thing and I
thought it was a disgrace why why duh
what why is it a disgrace at when you've
got like 45 channels and you hit all 45
channels there is 9 times there was at
least 16 channels hitting the same thing
about how she had gotten into the
accident what was going on with her and
and the gentleman that she was with I
mean quite honestly I don't care and it
was a disgrace to even think that that
this was so much wanting to be heard if
famous Oh Jay I was quite disgusted with
that what would you say though do a news
editor at a television network that says
my ratings just went through the ceiling
because we're talking about this girl
and that's a problem with the Rays on
television news I would never even
consider I have three papers that I get
I would never take anything there's
nothing coming on about anything that
goes on in the state of California about
the things that are really important
except how the dog or a snaky edge dog
or you know it what's weathers brought
on here 15 minutes every time there
there's no news coverage and and quite
honestly I guess they think that that's
what's making it but there is one thing
I'd like to ask mr. Hitchens about the
point of when he was talking about being
an American citizen and how there isn't
uh the people that that are migrating to
this country what he's talking about
these these people with these nuns in
California are they actually citizens of
the United I don't know I don't
understand how you can have a religious
affiliation and yet not be a citizen of
the United States I don't know if they
are aren't but I I think it's very
interesting thank you let me ask mr.
pretty respondent unit to answer a
question I don't know whether the nuns
are or so not the fact that they're you
know Buddhist nuns have the right of
just much right as a Catholic nun to be
a you know to participate
in our political process I would the
things that struck me though is how no
one has the people who normally get very
exercised about the so-called Christian
right getting involved in politics have
not been disturbed at all the fact that
this is a religious group that's
involving itself in a very big way in
politics there does seem to be a double
standard here if this were vice
president who had gone to a fundraiser
at Jerry Falwell Church in
Charlottesville Virginia this story
would've been all over the top of the
New York Times in the Washington Post
and been all over the network's they
still wouldn't have made the point that
you didn't make either yes it sounds
good when you say that Buddhist nuns
Catholic nuns any a religious elf has
the same right to participate in
politics virtually they have the same
right to stay out of it in my opinion as
long as they are granted tax exemption
which they can't be our head of lifting
that tax exemption and making or
churches pay taxes as I'm sure you are
but if they're not going to that I think
they have that the bargain is they stay
out of politics and they they honor the
separation of church and state as I'm
sure yeah well I would be for lifting
the tax exemption for church ventures
into profit-making like if they own
office buildings or parking lots or
something like that I don't think the
church is certainly not free they should
pay tax on their income I don't think
that they should pay taxes on their
collection plate why why why would that
be well it's because then I would give
to let the government come in and have a
say on what known their fundraising and
what they might say I just think it's a
I think the First Amendment prevents it
West Palm Beach Florida good morning oh
yes I just like to say I've I think the
coverage of Princess Diana and I'll call
her that because I think she is has been
wonderful and I get a little tired of
our Republican side condemning anything
that isn't sort of in their favor but no
I think it's wonderful the English
people have responded to a person who
has ricktum gone all over the world and
tried to help people and I
that's something we should all try to do
and as far as the nuns and the Christian
Right the Christian Right has spent
billions of dollars trying to get people
elected they've spent out sent up
pamphlets they speak terribly of our
president they talk to call them
terrible names awful names if you listen
to the radio and Pat Robinson on TV and
I haven't heard anything disgusting or
even close to that from these people
from California Thank You mr. Frieden
well I saw mr. Hitchens flesh when he
was in effect being accused of being a
Republican or at least a partisan of
Negara cons the big are well you know
I'm sure this lady expresses a point of
view that's a very widespread it's you
know the talk show expectations the talk
show mentality is very widespread out
there
I don't again I just think that there is
a something wrong with a sense of
proportion when a funeral for Diana
Spencer Princess Diana
becomes as big or maybe even bigger than
the funeral for Winston Churchill I mean
she's really not a heroine she is a you
know it's a very pretty young woman and
it's it's certainly very sad that she
was killed in his traffic accident again
it's entertainment that's what has
happened that I find so sad
this whole thing is taken on the
spectacle of Entertainment Tonight you
know what is there to say about it and I
bet you now perhaps you should change
your thing on the screen and say it
doesn't say Democrats and Republicans
says Royalists and Republicans should
Cornell because then we would get the
then I could own up to being a
Republican without strain well misery
I'm not a Republican either you know I
have to honest a little
I'm an independent I know you're honest
I'm glad to see well I enjoy I certainly
enjoyed the wedding of Diana and Charles
I think the note in your Vanity Fair
piece this month you talk about your
resentment of the idea that many
Americans seem to have that the royal
family is there as the star of a sort of
a theme park that Britain is for the
tourists and I can certainly understand
how you would feel resentful about that
I think that there is certain certainly
some value and in the monarchy as as a
tradition that holds the people together
however I defer to the British people
who know far more about that than I do I
do believe that it has a value as a
tradition this royal family seems intent
however on destroying and whatever value
it is let me ask though something that
our audience is out there saying well
for an outfit that doesn't think that
this ought to be talked about we're
talking about it for a whole hour and
for someone who doesn't like the Royals
you make your living off of writing
about the law Royals as you do here in
Vanity Fair what do you say to someone
well actually do me my living by any
means I thought of writing an article a
couple of months ago and the magazine
thought it was a good idea saying why
was that the British royal family was
all washed up and perhaps you'd like to
read a few of the amazing almost eerily
prescient paragraphs in that piece Ryan
is still on the stands by the way
available to find news agencies
everywhere give us a paragraph that you
will I said the various for various
reasons the Royal Family's going down
the drain one is the election of Tony
Blair who has been as you notice the
star of this week as he was the man who
coined the term people's princess
pointed out the royal family itself had
new no no knowledge or understanding of
the emotions or feelings of its subjects
I pointed that out that had been going
on for some time the replacement of a
monarchy by a presidential style and
then I said people keep asking me is but
isn't doesn't the royal family provide
magic and charisma and I said no it
doesn't the only person with any magic
and charisma and I don't think she has
that much of it is an ex-member of
people didn't understand she was she did
not die never the royal family should
been thrown out of that family so the
only person who can invoke it is someone
who doesn't like the family I didn't
know of course how apt that was going to
sound in a in a couple of weeks but the
fact remains that's that has become the
story this week let's go to San Diego
next go ahead please you're on the air
hi thank you my remarks really are
geared towards your guests but I think
particularly towards mr. Hitchens I did
see your parents on MSNBC and I really
you watch too much television that you
watch too much television well I'm on
unvoluntary vacation but but I I do
agree with much of what you said because
you were trying to get to the real
issues cooler mind unfortunately we
weren't prevailing but as I noticed as I
watched the coverage the extensive
coverage and I do think it's gotten out
of hand I think that people are just
going over the top even for the Congress
of pander to people and to make this a
national day of recognition and mourning
for her I don't remember that happening
for someone like Gandhi or I just think
it's that part is absolutely ridiculous
however something that I that I I'm not
a feminist but I've noticed that a lot
of the coverage most of the male guests
are male and it seems to me that they've
almost had a this this attitude towards
the women callers who have clearly
identified with Princess Diana for
whatever reason that they roll their
eyes for the most part and just cannot
understand when JFK RFK there are those
memories and of their assassinations or
their tragic untimely deaths are are
invoked and they say please she was no
JFK and when I kind of step back and I
look at those two individuals and I see
how they were in a privileged family and
in a privileged position and where
untimely it killed or died
and in the reaction that many people had
I really don't see much of a difference
she obviously had an impact and if you
look at it from that point when people
say she was a hero to me and again it's
primarily women and they see themselves
in their own struggles in her life I I
do think that it's somewhat diminishing
perhaps some of the value that that is
there for so many people maybe it's a
mass hysteria but I think the real
tragedy is for any child who loses a
parent that I think is is the real
tragedy
thanks well it's you know I don't
understand how women here can think that
they feel any identification with Diana
Spencer here was a and I saw a sentiment
like this expressed all week some of
these enter TV interviews at the at the
British Embassy for instance where young
women are saying I really identify with
Diana she and I were the same age we
married the same year one of them said
but here is a young woman who had been
to Central Paris on a vacation she flew
in a private jet to Paris had a dinner
that probably cost more than a lot of
people make in a month
by the incognito at the Paris Ritz as
well gets into a hundred and fifty
thousand dollar limousine and speeds off
into the night expecting to spend the
rest of the weekend and the kind of
apartment that very few people will ever
even see much less live in I really
don't understand how they feel any
identification with it but I think the
caller has a point though about the
Kennedy comparison we input the fact is
there are not because a lot of the
alleged charisma of the Kennedys is
transferred onto members of the Kennedy
family you've never done a thing not
even get shot like young John for
example I mean he's considered to be
Kennedy royalty for no other reason
except his surname by perhaps I suppose
those who remember the solution of the
funeral
that's that again is something he came
by service Pete Baxter so there is I
mean the there is a an extent to which
being a fan of Princess Diana is no
worse than shall we say that the
canonization will defecate oh I'd rather
there are the politicized public figures
I just want to say something about what
I mean by the my resentment of the
identification this country of Britain
with royalty as if we have nothing else
to offer as a culture my the country of
my birth the great contribution of the
English anyway to the to the worldís
English literature in language and the
that language in that literature is in
fact in its tradition quite extensively
Republican and Democratic I mean I Blake
Milton Shelley many many other great
writers virtually in prose have been
against the idea that Britain is a
feudal anarchic system and one of the
great aspects of that tradition is
represented by the name Thomas Paine who
is the moral author of your Declaration
of Independence so it always strikes me
in fact one of the great triumphs of the
English Republican movement if you like
is the American Declaration of
Independence so it's always struck me as
rather bizarre that there's this Cup in
the United States of English royalism
just the sort of thing that I left
England to get away from to the point of
a collar in San Diego you ought to know
that The Associated Press story that's
in a lot of papers including the
Washington Times it has a line Dianna's
week-long wake is too much for some
every person quoted in there is a man
and we get to the some of those quotes
and one of them is haven't we had an F s
Birmingham bond dealer Paul Randle
entering the Royal Automobile Club with
a furled umbrella on his arm and a copy
of the Financial Times protruding from
his grain leather attache case that's
you know it is curious also it struck me
as interesting that the networks which
are Bennett which have been very very
hard on the royal family this week
actually oh the family a debt because by
delaying the funeral for a week who had
struck me as a quite a long delay
disallowed the story to build and
allowed them to use the
everything for their ratings all week
I'm just curious
mr. Hitchens maybe you know is this it
isn't this a long time between a death
and a funeral or is this traditional for
the for the royal asking the wrong
person I don't know what's usual about
this and they contrasted abruptly of
course with the very hasty interment on
Muslim principles yes 3005 because
muslim law says you have to be
underground by the following sundown
Kansas and Missouri can I just make a
point about ratings yeah sure hold on
can't see me right with you I mean it's
easily that you if you're a television
executive you're you are entitled to say
looks do because the public likes them
we do that we did this for the ratings
we ran this show because it was ratings
we're good and so which you can't do
that with the news division you can't
say the news division is done by ratings
because news is telling people what they
don't already know so you cannot find
out that you're giving them what they
like in a trance because you can't know
it you can't know what their reaction is
going to be it's just antithetical to
news that's the first point they could
have covered a lot of Princess Diana
they could have given any fan of hers as
much coverage as he or she could
possibly have wanted but they needn't
have made the assumption that that's all
we wanted and then ended made the
assumption that we all felt the same way
about it the wall street it was at all
took it as seriously and that was
offensive and it made it seem as if we
lived in a one-party state that Wall
Street Journal editorial from Wednesday
I was reading earlier says there are no
brakes on the vehicles that drive that
TV drives and it careened into the
biggest crash since the OJ Simpson trial
turn it off at mid morning and go off to
get on with your life and when you
return in the evening it was still there
on the local or national news in New
York for example we witnessed interviews
before piles of flowers at the British
Consulate with women choking out that
quote her life was all about peace just
like John Lennon's and with spiky-haired
arraigned residents of the village
suggesting that a fitting memorial would
be quote if we all did something for
charity unquote and of course each
segment must end at all levels of the TV
hierarchy with the reporter's voice soft
as an Angels adding that quote we all
share unquote this or that or whatever
I will put and you saw how many people
actually sign the book of the rich
conservation Neil this week guess I just
saw it this morning
10,000 that's all but you would believe
the whole of New York was one round that
block Kansas predict it's ridiculous
Kansas City you're on you are trying to
undermine what Diana did accomplished in
a very short period of time these other
people that you are speaking about at a
very long time to accomplish what they
did accomplish and they had the support
of a lot of different people Diana had
to do it all alone she didn't have the
support of her of her royal family and
she did it she made a difference and I
don't know why you insist on undermining
and putting down what she did accomplish
we have no idea what she could have
accomplished in her entire lifetime and
yes I think she did a lot for Humanity
and for humankind and I do appreciate
the coverage because it brought that to
the attention of everybody rather than a
negative negative that always seems to
prevail the news okay stay where you are
just about let's get our reaction we'll
get you to come back well you know this
has allowed everybody to project their
own interpretation of what Diana
Princess Diana was she did I suppose you
could say that she brought attention to
the issue of land mines and she hugged
AIDS patients which is fine people who
need hugs should get hugs I suppose but
Diana Spencer did not accomplish very
much she was not a she was not a
government official she didn't do nearly
the work that some other people have
done who get no recognition she was
famous mostly for being famous
she wears she wore clothes very well as
a man I loved looking at her but beyond
that what did she accomplish let's go
back to our car and we'll come to mr.
Hitchens go ahead car
respond please this is exactly what I'm
talking about if you had watched the
news coverage you would have seen what
Diana has accomplished in a very short
amount of time she raised a lot of money
for a lot of different charities she was
a goodwill ambassador to a lot of
different countries including the United
States she was here several times on
goodwill missions so you cannot you
absolutely cannot deny that she had
accomplished a lot and that is one
reason I am glad that there was this
coverage so people like you cannot take
that away from her thank you mister it
well look it's um you can't argue with
quarrel with faith and you can't tell
someone who's in love that they're not
these things are unquantifiable people
who believe that she did a lot and
contributed a lot and made a difference
and so on I always see stuck with that
belief I don't think I know of a single
celebrity who doesn't have a signature
charity for example I mean it's part of
being the celebrity you you do your
charity work with some celebrities it
looks more like an accessory than it
does with others with her it didn't look
like an accessory I mean she could go
from being the woman who had did the
gold-digging divorce settlement in which
she asked among other things for a
private plane and got two palaces and
600 million pounds in cash to one photo
op in Angola and people would remember
the photo op in Angola
now her her dowdy boring former
sister-in-law Princess Anne who's been
the patron of the Save the Children
front for I think 25 years now goes
trudging around Africa looking like a
fright in her boots and so on up to here
in mud and so on all the time covered in
flies and so on doing the salesmen no
one cares no one bothers to send a
camera after she's not photogenic for
one thing she's a boring from but she
really is a spadework charity worker the
fact is nobody can really tell you what
Princess Diana actually did but if if
they believed that she did it in a sense
she did do but it's it's exactly that
confusion what Daniel Boston in his book
on the non-event unit says being well
known for being well-known the only one
hopes doesn't become the only value
in the selection of news priorities
that's all Nashville we're not a rain on
your parade now Nashville go ahead
please yes I would like to say that I
honor the memory of Diana the Princess
of Wales and frankly Brian I'm appalled
at your guest this morning and I would
like to say further that there are two
kinds of pair per se or these
photographers that chase celebrities on
motorcycles and cars they're the kind
that you have there this morning that
all they do is sit and malign and
criticize and try to defame someone's
honor and memory and I want to tell you
something else
Brian there's something more in life
than just criticizing and maligning I
honor Diana because she hugged a sick
child because she did take the hand of
someone who was dying with AIDS I'm glad
she was there to do it I honor her
memory and I didn't know her and I
probably would never get to meet her but
I think she was a wonderful person
I think her memory is going to live on
and I'm disgusted by the comments of mr.
Putin and mr. Hitchens and mr. Hitchens
I've got something to tell you you're in
this country criticizing the Royals
that's very easy to do I would like to
see you go back to England and criticize
them over there oh please that's easy
I can well I get sharing that to me Tory
objections as you see someone whose
voice shows borderline hysteric and not
only that she's had a whole week where
everything on every every inch of air
time if you have inches of time every
moment of that time has been set up to
suit people like her moist semi cheerful
and she sees two people for a few
moments who don't agree and she's in a
state about it she can't take even that
this is the sort of this is sort of
cheap emotion on which the things we
based is exactly what we're objecting to
as for the
mother I should go back home to say this
I say it all the time anything that I
published a book a critique of the
monarchy saying it's time for it to fold
its tense and go which wasn't a popular
but when it came out it's got more
popular since you may be glad to hear
ma'am let me ask our caller Nashville
ma'am administration just said that you
are are the way you are because yours
you've been subject to all this coverage
what's your reaction to that my reaction
to mr. Hitchens and mr. Putin and
yourself Brian I'm a human being and I
have a great deal of respect for other
human beings that tried to do something
to help people in whatever way they can
and I know that this young person of 30
36 years did as much as she possibly
could within her status I know of people
that can do so much more and do nothing
except write articles criticizing and
maligning people mister prudence said
something about an automobile accident
indeed I hope mr. Putin you're never in
an automobile accident in that manner
well I appreciate that she's not as if
she really means she'll know it as well
you're right
well of course and and then I hope
you're never in an automobile accident
or that for whatever that may have to do
with it you know and one thing piece of
advice I could give you is stay out of
cars driven by a mad drunk men of course
I have said at the top of the show that
I regret the death of Diana Spencer the
Princess of Wales I think she did do
some good things
it's the excess of coverage that we're
talking about here this morning I we're
not talking about whether it is a sad
occasion that a beautiful young woman
died in an automobile accident of course
it is but it's the it's the excess of
coverage and I also say that my own
newspaper has perhaps been guilty of it
as well but there are more things going
on
more important than this outpouring of
hysteria over a young woman the death of
a young woman that we all regret by the
way there are a lot of faxes coming in
on this very strong opinions on both
sides here's one of them it says thank
you thank you thank you for having
Christopher Hitchens and West pruden on
this proves that at least two members of
the media had their heads screwed on
straight and have not been caught up in
the grand illusion and maudlin wallow
that the TV media has created
made-for-tv indeed thanks again
one thing in Diana's favor this comes
from Dan Valentine of Philadelphia she
was or appeared to be intelligent and
sophisticated American culture seems to
revel in the exact opposite in music
lots of swearing revealing clothing TV
and movie stars always talking about
themselves and their sex life sports
figures lots of trash talk I'm the
greatest etc the only intelligent people
in popular culture are the bad guys in
movies and they end up dead here is one
that says we all human beings we are all
human beings none of us are Saints
editor prudence stop dismissing Diana as
a pretty bit of fluff want to comment
quickly well I think she was very pretty
here if none of us are Saints then stop
canonizing Princess Diana they can't
have it both ways
here's from David Hannah's Esquire Coral
Springs Florida gentlemen will none of
you recognize the similarities with
JFK's death and Jackie O successful
marriage into the Hitchens
characterization of the international
white-trash Jet Set how's that again
will none of you let me read it again
well none of you recognize the
similarities with JFK's death and Jackie
hos successful marriage into the
Hitchens characterization of the
international white-trash Jet Set it's
not grammatical that question I didn't I
gently understand it dies I see there's
a vague association of ideas well on
that note we'll go to Naples Florida
good morning
Maureen Brian how you doing I'm fine sir
what's on your mind
ah
I tend to agree with you you know I tend
to agree I've had the same feeling that
this has been over you know over covered
not so I haven't I followed I tried to
follow the news details of it of what
actually happened in the crash so forth
and so far so on I guess I'm just
wondering why your why your guests are
having to get so personal you know why
and what was in what way they started
out talking about the excess coverage of
the tragedy okay that's fine but then
they go on and say yeah you know
Princess Diana she's just a pretty face
he's just this she's just that why do
you think why do you have to get
personal about it well let me ask you
this why do you think people obviously
just listening this morning feels he
wants impersonal coverage of princess
yeah but but they felt why do people
feel so I said he you seem to be wanting
impersonal coverage of Princess Diana I
wish you all the luck in the world
what is the discuss except the
personality here that's what we're
saying why do you have to create why do
you have to why do you have to sit there
and look down your nose been criticized
do you want to make me to make it really
simple for you because the story is
entirely about your personality if you
want impersonal coverage you are doomed
disappointment we have two objections or
I do one is it's too much coverage of
any personality a second insofar as this
personality is the centerpiece of
Titanic coverage I would say it's a
rather meager personality are not very
great are not very not very not very
distinguished life and not very
important human being caller come back
so then going after the press for doing
those things instead of going in what I
believe I think I think I can I think I
can look you in the eye if I can see you
back and say that we I have done that
all morning you're a hard person to
please to her personally that's you yes
yes both thing let me ask you to prune
to jump in hold on to the line what's
your reaction to this criticism well you
know of course it's personal we're
talking about a person I don't think
that that our criticism
has been that the Dyna sprinter the
Princess of Wales is a bad person I
think we both agree that she was
probably a good person she and I will
say that she did some very good things
it's just that the comparison of this
young woman who lived a jet-set life and
that's the that's the life she wanted to
compare her to someone who has really
had a lifetime of accomplishment to my
mind is preposterous if I don't if that
makes me seem cold and unfeeling I don't
mean for two but I'll take that chance
Koller Naples your response right I
don't know I just been sitting here all
hour and I mean some of the comments
just have seen totally unnecessary let
me ask you this because I'll go back to
the Wall Street Journal editorial that I
haven't read the whole thing but a lot
of it and there seems to be a great deal
of difference between the way people
think and there they're looking at the
media story here and here's what what
they said it is an odd and frustrating
experience surely shared by viewers
everywhere you've come into the event
looking mainly for information and
perspective and eventually unavoidably
inevitably you emerge from your time
before the screen a cynic even in the
face of death oh yes the common answer
to all this one simply can choose not to
watch we guess so but the fact is that
this is a world we live in and we can't
escape the conclusion that a great
technology is a terrible thing to waste
fundamentally this is the same lens
based technology that wrote aboard the
tiny Pathfinder as it traversed Mars
sending back wondrous images the same
technology that has turned the tensions
of athletic competition into an entirely
justifiable viewer addiction what is
your response to that take on this whole
story that's an easy one Brian you have
to be selective you have to watch shows
like yours you pick out what yes we do
have all this media thrown at us you
select the ones you want to watch that's
why I'm sitting here watching c-span
this morning and gun complaining that
we've changed the subject let's go to
San Francisco
go ahead San Francisco you're on the
line yes I've been watching the coverage
in the media very carefully this week
and it's quite fascinating
to see the power of the image that can
be built by the media in creating in the
masses of humanity and idea about what a
person is really like when I see the
coverage of the royal family and
particularly focus on Prince Charles and
his two sons and what is said about
Diana it's very strange that them when
they point out Charles's adultery and
his misdeeds they seem to clearly
overlook
Diana's embarrassing behavior her
fragrant adultery and the effect that
that has on her sons when they make her
a heroine to young women throughout the
world surely they must realize that some
of the things that she's done has been a
great embarrassment and not an example
for the young woman's world so what I
what I'm looking at I look at what's
been said about Diana being um you know
like a naive young woman coming into the
royal family she's a Spencer what I
heard was even to the media that the
Spencer's had been mistresses to the
royal family for centuries so my point
is not that Diana is a bad person but
this madness we have problems with
promiscuity with young women in America
why is this particular woman who in many
ways has really turned the whole world
against her own country and in some
circles may even be considered
treasonous why is she being elevated to
the point of almost some type of goddess
this seems like madness why do you think
are well I think that there are some
factions in the world that would like to
see all monarchies got away with and I'm
not debating that issue but there may be
some other sinister things that are
under the table but whatever
happening people ought to stop this
madness and clearly looked and judge
people fairly don't just jam the royal
family and Prince Charles and and
overlook some of the indiscretions of
Diana because that's not justice that
imbalance thanks collar attentions well
yes there are some people who think that
the royal house should be done away with
I'm certainly one of them and I find it
odd that I should have to argue this in
in an America that's based on a
rebellion against the terrible
Hanoverians Princess Diana as you say
was a voluntary member of that dynasty
she didn't have to be in it she joined
it she didn't behave very well in it she
was a spoiled kid she didn't she didn't
realize that there was more to it than
just being the fairytale princess she
rebelled against the idea that you have
to sacrifice anything for duty or
tradition an idea that rather gloomy
husband certainly overdid but
nonetheless that he he does possess a
sense of responsibility she thought
surely this means if your princess life
is a party when she came to America she
could have met anyone she liked they
said who do you want to be said John
Travolta that was his princess she never
read a book from beginning to end
she's a borderline airhead in fact was a
bore liner had gold Digga a tremendous
gold digger with a sharp lawyer did a
tremendous job of cashing in on her own
divorce did in return for this one day
in Bosnia one day in Angola and was very
nice to person was actually a friend of
mine Adrian wood Jackson when he was
telling evades when the royal family
told him maybe aids wasn't the right
cause I'll give her all that but that's
all she wrote that's it
and the most abysmal taste in men some
of them as the caller says married to
other women whose lives were made
miserable by the princess so and the guy
she was actually trying to get off with
when his bodyguards and the to imagine
the sort of people who are bodyguards
for the al-fayed family and the Paris
Ritz Hotel that whether fired family has
boasted of buying British
parliamentarians and bribing and
blackmailing them in the last few months
alone imagine the sort of characters
you're running with there a final choice
of guy was the perhaps the worst of all
well I can't add much that you know the
thing I don't the idea that that Diana
was some vulnerable young woman who was
being mistreated by the royal family she
was actually very clever if if not as
intelligent as a lot of people think she
may have been and I have to think that
this this romance with with Dodi Fayed
might might very well have been a
strategy on her part I can't believe
that she did not know that she could not
marry this man because if she had she
probably would have turned the British
people against her overnight because of
of all kinds of political reasons why
she couldn't marry she was the mother of
a future king of England she could not
marry a Muslim and to be about it and
she knew that well the law of the
British law only says she can't marry a
Catholic well now with the laws I think
the public family as I broke mine did
well but it's the British people would
have been very I think I've died defer
to your judgment on this but I would
think that they would would find that
that was inappropriate in the same way
that when Jackie Kennedy married Onassis
she lost a lot of the luster and a lot
of the glitter and not because he was
Grievous no because he was a he did not
strike most people as the is the kind of
prince who should marry a princess I
don't think that um there would have
been any really serious objection my
marrying a Muslim but I think we are
fired family they are fired business
dynasty which has been found by British
courts and investigators to be unfit
ready for the stewardship of public
business I mean that's the I'm putting
it politely here would would have
created a problem for yes but she went
into that obviously with her eyes.if and
UNITA got to get a call where we're
running out of time we gotta go to the
house early today let's go to Cleveland
next go ahead please hi Brian
hi thanks the c-span Hartford
Connecticut has been nicknamed Nashville
Tennessee that woman called not only
lying to you is saying she was going
from Nashville but she called earlier
this week so she should sort of be
banned for life because she called so
often yeah we can't catch her and it's a
sad I think though what she had to say
is that which side did she taken this oh
she was as I recall very Pro Diana yes
she was Joe we need that this morning so
it was but I appreciate what you're
saying I know she drives us crazy and
I'm sorry we can't catch her go ahead
with your comments cuz we're running out
of time what I wanted to say was that
the this thing comes down fact that she
was killed by a drunk driver period
there's nothing more you have to say and
we have had perhaps a year of television
news hysteria about smoking and yet
people something like 20,000 a year in
America killed by these drunk drivers
and none of them are volunteers except
the drivers themselves whereas people
who die from smoking-related illnesses
are all volunteers now you talk about
and by the way finally they got around
to nailing who they probably caused this
accident talking about our TV news
people and that is the tabloids
oh my god those horrible tabloids and
even some of these news people in
America blamed finally got to blaming
Rupert Murdoch the bettan waa of all
television news oh god this evil man who
caused all this to start with
I might mention two other things I heard
someone say Mozart died at the age of 36
I don't know if that's true or not and
as far as Diana and AIDS
I personally I'm just very saddened by
this kind of a death really and I worry
a lot about the children being thrust
into this horrible family but anyway I
have to run let me say this about a yes
in her interview with the BBC she said
that she took William and Harry to visit
AIDS patients but she told them it was
cancer thank you we brought in some
trouble powder yeah we're in trouble
it's trouble anyway last comment before
the house comes in oh I didn't know we
doubtless coins um at the Republic this
has brought a republic much nearer and
so that in the search for meaning in
what is indeed only a sordid traffic
accident there may be in our intended
consequence and I think I think that's
the that's the ray of sunshine as the
silver lining young women of all ages
should be very careful who they go out
with is that your last debts of my life
daddy and that's our last comment for
this Washington journal on a Friday
thank you for joining us we're awaiting
the arrival of someone in the House of
Representatives as you will see